For the time being, it seems like it's fine as before Sayo-
san should know that you're doing fortune-telling.
Hidden backflow Malphy
was feared as a troublemaker, but he
fell in love with the general of the imperial troupe, and
when the empire collapsed, he should have eloped with him.
I don't
buy the whole thing to make dragon zombies.They've been
games or comics since a while ago, but they're
only talking.Or is it a light
novel?
It looks like
it's a waste of magic It's not a big deal if it's this much It
doesn't make that kind of sound even if you're playing a game It doesn't make that kind of sound It
might be the sound of writing something Maybe it's the
sound of a TRPG clattering dance Even so,
Xiaoyu-kun is the only one  You're so enthusiastic about your work that you're
still not sleeping, it's like you're protecting Sayo-san I
can't sleep, I'm
in front of Sayo-san's room You know I'm
here again There weren't any surveillance cameras here
I told you, okay, I'll slowly
uncover your true identity.It's good for Haley's blood.